it felt like the pressure from the
outside was just like squeezing me into
something smaller and smaller
[Music]
hello everybody happy
wednesday
uh it's about two o'clock in the
afternoon i wanted to show you a quick
little bit of how cool our like bedroom
is now um i've realized that i haven't
really filmed a house tour since
basically we moved in it's kind of fun
to watch that video because a lot has
changed but our bedroom is one such area
where it's changed a lot fiddly fig is
thriving here we put curtains up we
change this to be light filtering shade
so we get more lighting and
look at this nightstand i found on
craigslist
two for three hundred dollars
mid-century modern furniture
that will always be a hobby of mine i
think finding like mid-century furniture
on craigslist and then our bed we've
been using um
linen sheets which like is really nice
because scott is a really hot sleeper
and linden sheets are very very
breathable but it's looking
much homier than it probably did in the
video so i wanted to take a moment to
thank the sponsor of today's video helix
sleep they
are the ones that gave us this mattress
we've been sleeping on this mattress for
about a year cause i've been working
with them for about a year now and it's
still a great mattress like we slept on
this thing every single night and the
quality has not gone down it's like just
as good as when we first got it so
anytime anybody's asking me for a
mattress recommendation
literally like to my friends i'm like
dude helix sleep is where it's at so yes
one of the things that i've talked about
often in my videos about how i kind of
like try to stay mentally physically
healthy like sleep i sleep so much eight
to nine hours a day is like my typical
thing if not more and so having a really
good mattress that allows me to get a
good night's sleep is really really
important helix sleep makes premium
mattresses that are customized to fit
exactly your needs and get conveniently
shipped to your door everybody sleeps
different and helix knows that and so
they've created a sleep quiz so that you
can tell it what kind of sleeper you are
and then it'll match you to the perfect
mattress i tend to be like a back
sleeper and i like a medium firm
mattress i also sleep with scott on the
bed and so we were matched with the dusk
luxe mattress i actually recently gifted
two helix mattresses as part of this
partnership one to my younger brother
who just moved into his first apartment
as an adult and then also my friend who
just recently had a newborn who needed
another mattress for their spare room i
asked them their honest and candid
opinion and thoughts about their
mattresses and this is what they had to
say i think it's like one of the best
beds i've ever slept on to be honest
so i'm like a rotisserie chicken when i
sleep
so i literally like roll around like i'm
like back and i'm on my side and then
i'm on my stomach and then i'm on my
side and then my back
sort of i put in in the survey i kind of
like put in like oh i also i tend to
sleep all around like multiple different
positions and
i think the midnight lux was the one
that they recommended it's not like one
of those like beds that you get online
where you just like sink right through
it and feel like the frame at the bottom
the way they balance the soft top and
the firm bottom it's like just right for
me
i think a cool part about this bed is
that like you take a serve survey at the
beginning on the
on the website so that you actually get
the best bet available for you
and just from like a product design
perspective
i think it's like it there's a lot of
care and attention that's put into
like making sure that you get a bed that
actually works for your sleeping style
to get the best bed available for you
and just from like a product design
perspective
i think it's like it there's a lot of
care and attention that's put into
like making sure that you get a bed that
actually works for yourself awesome i
love having it as a backup to our
regular bed
and just be you know i feel so rested
the next morning this is my first time
uh
having a mattress that got shipped to me
uh but i have to say like the quality is
super good and it and i just really
enjoyed how easy was to just get it to
my house how does olivia like the best
she loves it it's very soft and i think
she just really likes to have like that
extra space and for real like we also
have the helix mattress in our guest
room and every guest that we've had like
the after the first night they sleep
here they're like dude i slept like so
well and so i literally think you cannot
go wrong with this mattress they deliver
the mattress straight to your door for
free although i will say you should
probably get a friend to help you lug it
up if you need to go up a bunch of
stairs because it is heavy and if it
makes you nervous to buy something that
you haven't tried before then they have
a 100 night sleep trial and so if you
try it for over three months and you
don't like it then you can send it back
and get a full refund they also have a
10-year warranty and flexible payment
plans and stuff like that and so they've
made it really easy for you to also get
to the mattress so if you're looking for
a new bed then definitely check out
helix you can click the link below in
the description box or go to
helixsleep.com
hello myuco to get up to 200 off your
very own mattress i
just about really want to take a nap
like right now because like 2 30 is when
i'm like sleepiest
so uh
i think i am going to do that because my
brain is mush
this is a video
this is our friend tracy
went to college again
okay
these are all of my college friends
and it's hot and we're waiting for the
bar to open
[Music]
scott
all all good nights in san diego and
with biographies
including the last time we were here
was our wedding
and we didn't eat at our wedding so we
came here
and we sat right there
and i think i had caramel sour fries and
you had a fresh bread yes which is
exactly what we got today
but wedding was fun
i'm so tired
it's almost 11 it's only 11.
[Music]
it's my birthday
yay
almost middle-aged almost little age
no
fine
you are middle-aged now i'm i'm
middle-aged
inside now you're you're
old ancient age inside if i'm ancient
then you're like
eternal i have a young i'm a young
a young soul
you're your
grandpa status i've always been like
that since i was like 16.
look at how pretty it is
i'm so afraid of the waves coming behind
[Music]
[Music]
all right i made
carambolar
swedish
cardamom buns
taste test this looks so good this looks
a lot better cheers
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god that's so good
oh yeah
that is a success
i am
so proud of myself
it's good that i only made six
because
it's not gonna last
we're gonna eat this
all
tonight
we have more tonight um
tomorrow too happy
saturday
today it's like a little afternoonish
but uh today chloe and kevin are coming
over from la and we're gonna hang out
eat tacos at some point we're gonna eat
sandwiches they're gonna be here any
minute so excited to hang out with them
and hopefully show them around sd a
little bit probably go to the beach it's
really hot today but
hopefully that won't stop us
[Music]
[Music]
there's only two sizes left
i've been wanting halloween costumes for
the dogs
this is perfect
is this what's this for the head for the
head yeah
[Laughter]
oh no
is it barely you fed us
[Music]
[Music]
okay
is this one for benny
um yeah we have three
we have three oh wow they're all
matching yeah
actually this one's specifically for
benny where's benny
look at you
you little cutie
you cutie gotta show your bandana
yay
thank you guys
[Music]
good
morning what day is it wednesday it's
wednesday hello everybody
scott and i have just been
socializing
and has
had like no breaks to just like chill
for like the last month or so and i feel
like it shows in my face because it's
like very puffy and stuff you know just
like
probably a lot of y'all are feelings too
but like post we're kind of moving
slowly cautiously moving into post cover
time
where like you hang out with people and
then you're just like i haven't
socialized like a whole
freaking year i'm very out of practice i
could feel it because my anxiety started
to kick in and my body was just like
where you go let you go there you go
you're not taking care of yourself and
we need to do something about it
so
i actually thought of this like drawing
of like
all these external pressures
or like squeezing
things out of me whether that be videos
or like work or advice or
hanging out or friendship or something
it felt like the pressure from the
outside was just like squeezing me into
something smaller and smaller and i was
vomiting
whatever and now i'm really focused on
just like building the internal pressure
back within me i guess today i am
filming a video
um later
and i'm pretty excited for it because
i'm just gonna let myself go and just
like film and make whatever if i feel
like making i guess i usually don't do
that as part of my like creative process
but
i think i need time to creatively play
and if i can do that in a video because
videos
are literally
a figure of my creativity why not you
know
that's okay that's okay everything will
be okay you know what i am proud about
though i am proud of the fact that i was
able to
like tell that like i was entering this
state of just like not having enough
energy for myself and like not having
enough internal pressure to go to grow
outwards and all the external stuff is
growing inwards and crushing me because
november is like
when i had my big mental health
crisis in 2019
i just entered a very dark period of
like
extreme anxiety
panic attacks always
so november always makes you reflect
like oh how far have i come since that
one day that was really really scary
and
i think there's just something about
october
that like it feels like there there's
like this force that's just like
pushes you faster than you can run
at least for me i mean a lot of it is my
own doing yes i know but
the october before
my
panic attacks i'm pretty sure i wasn't
cognizant of the signs that i was
not taking care of myself i guess now
that i look back on it and now like i
noticed that if i'm a little anxious i'm
like oh that's a sign then i'm not doing
enough for myself
so i have gotten better
i think sleep is a big part of it i have
been trying to sleep more
and
eating well
and literally just creating periods in
the day where i don't have to do
anything
big
big thing that helps me
also like just watching tv shows like
not needing to like answer to anything
or anyone is pretty important too i'm
actually going on a trip
my first vacation
like out of town
that's not the bay area since covered
basically scott and i are going to the
east coast
which i'm really excited for one of the
best things about vacations is that no
one asks anything of you while you're
out there because
you're on vacation i feel like i put on
too much
foundation
but you know what maybe this i should
just take this as another creative
opportunity
like hey you know what sometimes you get
to just paint your face because it's fun
and why not and you get to reap the
rewards for the rest of the day
look at yourself in the mirror and be
like oh hey
you're looking good today bro
by the way for all you interested in
makeup you want to know what i'm using
i've posted
like a lot of my makeup products haven't
changed so if you look through any of my
other videos
where i talk about what products are
using you can look there i will say the
one thing that i really like using is
this thing laura mercier's tinted
moisturizer
[Music]
that's fine leave it where you don't
touch it
[Music]
don't
touch
[Music]
and now i've got a full face i'm gonna
go film this video of mine
before lunch ideally
deep breath
ready
see you in that video or soon
soon
[Music]
you